quand on est sous l'eau on est dans la
pesanteur la plus totale en dessous et
bien un bleu de plus en plus profond
dentier à découvrir
qu'est ce qu'on entend calypso va pas
acheter saab déjà sept ses bateaux si
notre rêve à tous les deux qu'on va
réaliser
pourquoi tu reste pas ici sera avec nous
vous allez bien partent à la conquête de
l'espace dianou nous partons à la
conquête de la mer
tu es prêt à faire n'importe quoi pour
du fric en fait tu vois tu parles
tapuach raconter une belle histoire bien
bidon bien et galop comme thème le
commandant cousteau et son équipage se
lie d'amitié avec des animaux sauvages
mais c'est super c'est génial bravo
s'est déclaré
jeune association la folie la tête sous
l'eau l'immensité à la pureté
oui
toutes ces années quand je te regarde et
avancer comme ça sur notoire je t'admire
des témoins ont parlé
nous sommes
j'étais moi toujours beaucoup parleurs
jacques
plus de trente ans j'ai découvert un
nouveau monde
je veux le conquérir voilà qu'en fait il
fallait le protéger ça
mais il est encore temps
e
corps
thomas
encore
tél
un salaire de la vie ouais
ça
il y avait
imagine tout ce qui reste à découvrir
explorer qu'est ce qui se cache au soir